spotted by Sky News on his golf course
at lunchtime a former president
preparing to be arrested
it was inside his residence here last
night at 7pm When Donald Trump's phone
rang
his lawyer told him that he was to be
indicted to face seven federal charges
among them Espionage allegations within
minutes of the call ahead of the
prosecutors who were out to get him he
was owning the moment the narrative and
the headlines because its election
interferes at the highest level there's
never been anything like what's happened
I'm an innocent man
person
his advisors who are with him here at
the golf club say he is in good spirits
and that he will fight this he said to
be huddled with lawyers presumably
contemplating Tuesday's extraordinary
arrest
it is all about these documents and it
is a huge development legally and
politically it's unprecedented
this is the scene of the alleged crime
or crimes Mar-A-Lago his Florida Resort
in August last year the FBI raided this
home of a former president at the heart
of the case of 15 boxes containing 184
documents marked as confidential secret
and top secret witness testimony and
CCTV were collected
then this man Jack Smith a judge
respected on both sides was appointed by
the Attorney General as special counsel
to take on the case a grand jury of
ordinary Americans examined it the
conclusion there is a case for Mr Trump
to answer
Glenn kirschner is a former Federal
prosecutor he will be fingerprinted he
will have his arrest photo taken and
then he will be transported to court
where he'll make his first court
appearance the indictment will be read
he will enter a plea presumably of not
guilty they'll turn their attention to
what conditions of release the judge
might set for Donald Trump then they
will pick a next court date top
Republicans are reacting already this is
hugely politically charged Speaker of
the House Kevin McCarthy wrote I and
every American who believes in the rule
of law stand with President Trump
against this grave Injustice House
Republicans will hold this Brazen
weaponization of power accountable
it is the voters who will drive the
direction of all this remember he is Far
and Away the favorite to be the
Republican candidate for the presidency
and a trial may not conclude before the
election
in April he was indicted in a New York
District Court over hush money payments
to a porn star they were not federal
charges
then a civil jury found him liable for
the sexual abuse of this woman
journalist e Gene Carroll his polling
went up
this will test America politically
legally socially The Divide will deepen
the split between those who want Trump
in court and those who believe this is
an attempt by Joe Biden to remove his
likely opponent rather than face him at
The Ballot Box brace for Jeopardy and
turbulence ahead